all right we're ready to get started
sorry it was a little late I ran out of
regular milk for my coffee and so I'm
having to use oat milk which is clearly
far inferior so if I'm a little bit
irritable today that's why okay so I
actually do like vegan food but real
milk in my coffee is essential okay so
um when we wrapped up last time
hopefully you can hear me on unzoom
somebody tell me if you can hear me on
Zune great alright um when we finished
up last time we were talking about
quorum consistency or quorum systems and
this question about if a client is
talking to several replicas how many
replicas should they talk to should they
talk to both for reading and writing um
so this is the picture that we drew at
the end of last time for that so we were
considering a system with three replicas
and and trying to figure out what would
make sense for the for the client to
talk to say that they wanted to have
strong consistency say that we we wanted
to make sure that that replicas agreed
and that the client wasn't able to
observe any replication anomalies if
that's the what we wanted
then this strategy of read one write all
would work so we could say three
replicas all of the replicas have to
acknowledge a write operation so the
client writes to all three and the
writes not considered to have committed
until all of them acknowledge it but for
a read to the client the client only has
to talk to one so that's that's one way
of configuring things and it's very
popular the trouble with this of course
is that it's not fault tolerant in the
sense that if a node crashes then you
can't do a write at all
so or if or if there's a network
partition that separates some notes from
the client then you can't do a write at
all no right can commit of course
other strongly consistent replication
strategy is like primary backup and
chain replication have the same problem
as we've seen um so so this is a this is
a problem well it may not surprise you
to learn that read one write all is not
the setting that the dynamo paper
suggests using so in fact when you have
three replicas of what do they suggest
in the Dynamo paper
does anyone recall sounds like
somebody's mic is on if you could mute
yourself please
so zoom is acting a little bit strange
for me it just muted me and I had to
unmute myself so I don't know how much
of what I just said people heard let me
start over so so we're in this setting
where we have three replicas and we and
we know that if we said that the right
coram was three and the reed poram was
one then then we would get something
like strong consistency we would get
strong consistency now before we define
strong consistency is meaning the client
can't observe that the data is
replicated at all
so here the client is in fact talking to
three different replicas so they do know
in some sense that the data is
replicated but it is strongly consistent
it would be strongly consistent in the
sense that the client can't observe any
replication anomalies so that's what we
would get if we had this setting of
setting setting the right quorum to
three in the Reed forum to one but that
has problems
in terms of fault tolerance and also
rights are slow so what does the paper
suggest doing instead
more zoom issues let me try this again
has that
great
about the technical difficulties
we're not even so somebody asked a
question it had to do with the the ring
of nodes so you're actually jumping
ahead of a little bit so we're going to
talk about that a lot but even before we
get to that we can talk about this this
question of how big the reed quorums and
right forums need to be so okay so the
the dynamo paper has a suggestion
they suggest setting the reed quorum to
two and the right forum to two when we
have three nodes so what would happen
then
well okay let's say we do a write of a
particular key and then we read it um
well something like this could happen so
we have our three replicas client does a
write to two replicas they both
acknowledge it and then the client asks
uh what the value of x is well because
the write quorum is to the client might
see a stale value of x over here right
let's say that X was four over here so
if they're read happens to hit these two
replicas
then they'll get some different values
for X right they'll get that X is five
and they'll get that X is four or
whatever this replica over here thought
that X was um but there is some
guarantee that you get right because the
read and the write quorums overlap you
know that you're gonna get at least one
response that has the latest right now
you may or may not have a good conflict
resolution strategy over here on the
client you're gonna find out that one
replica thinks X is five and then
another one thinks X is four and you
have to figure out what to do about that
but at least you know that you're going
to see the most recently written data in
at least one of the responses that you
get um
now sometimes R is defined differently
so here I'm defining R as being the
number of replicas that have to
acknowledge a read and W is the number
of replicas that have to acknowledge it
right now in some settings if R is two
then that would mean you have to hear
back from at least two replicas with the
same value I've seen it defined that way
in some places but I don't think that
that's what the Dynamo paper means by it
I think they just mean two replicas have
to acknowledge the right and they might
come back with different values so in
general here there are three replicas so
in here was three in general if we
ensure that our plus W is greater than n
then we know that every read quorum is
going to intersect with every right
Quora and we won't get what's known as a
stale read where all of the responses
that we get back are too small so in
particular if we had chosen a read
quorum of only one if we'd had a right
quorum of two but a read quorum of one
then we could have been doing our rights
to replicas one and two doing our reads
from replicas three and we would never
see any of the rights that we had done
so this is the inequality that you need
to know
for figuring out how to set R and W of
course if you choose that read one write
all setting so in this example then read
one is so so so R would be one then W
would be three so this of course
satisfies this property because n in
that case is three so that so the read
one right all setting would satisfy that
property but so would this other setting
where you only read two and write two
now this wouldn't give you strong
consistency in the sense that you would
still be able to observe that these two
replicas had different states but you
would at least have this property that
somebody's going to send you the most
recently written data and this is indeed
the the settings that the setting that a
lot of systems go with and this is what
they use for the experiments in the
paper there's a lot more to say there's
more to say on quorum consistency but
that's that's the short version um
Oh somebody asked what was wrong with
doing doing read one write all well it's
slow right if I had to wait to get every
replica to acknowledge me uh before
before a right had committed then that
would be slow so it's the same problem
that we see happening with with the
other strongly consistent replication
strategies that we looked at like
primary backup and chain replication so
it's it's so any any time you want to
ensure strong consistency it's gonna be
slower than if you aren't ensuring
strong consistency all right so that's
all I really want to say about that um
that's the short version quorum
consistency um I want to move on to
something new today so we're going to
start talking about charting today
also known as data partitioning not to
be confused with network partitions so
network partitions are when some nodes
can't communicate with other nodes data
partitioning has to do with how you
split up your data among nodes
different thing it's one of those
annoying situations and distributed
systems where we're using the same term
to mean totally different things okay so
we spent a lot of time talking about
replication right which is having
multiple copies of the same data on
different notes and in the systems that
we've talked about so far every replicas
stores all the data so you might have a
bunch of different machines and let's
say it's a key value store you have a
bunch of different key value pairs and
every replica has all the key value
pairs and so your clients are over here
talking to replicas are there any
problems with doing it this way with
putting all the data on all of the
replicas what do you think
yeah lots of good suggestions so so
scalability is mentioned so yeah maybe
if you have more data than can actually
fit on a single machine then maybe you
can't do this right let's say let's say
you have you know you can you can scale
up at an individual machine to a certain
point right but at some point that
becomes much more expensive than just
having more than one machine and then
there's this let's say let's say you're
doing primary backup for instance that
means all of your reads and writes are
being served by one machine the primary
so if you have lots of clients making
lots of requests and the primary has to
do a lot of work and you can't just talk
to the backups so that's kind of what
I've Illustrated here say these clients
are talking to this machine maybe this
machine here is the primary but what if
you did this
so now you've split up your data across
these machines and they don't have to be
kept consistent with one another right
because they're all storing totally
disjoint parts of the data set of course
now we lost replication right we only
have one copy of each so we don't have
fault tolerance but we could put it back
we could call this M 1 1 M 2 1 and M 3 1
and then we could have some other
machines here
okay so now we have now we have
replication again and we've also split
up the data set among multiple machines
so splitting up the data set like this
among multiple nodes is known as
charting or data partitioning so we've
got shards like this
also sometimes known as replica groups
so why would you do this well one reason
might be to improve throughput right now
if you have clients that need to read
all this data right and the requests are
more or less split up evenly across the
space of key value pairs then it might
make sense to have several machines
serving those requests instead of just
one and then the other reason of course
is if you just can't fit all your data
in one node then you might need to split
it up so so reasons to do sharding
include improving throughput
and storing large amounts of data so in
this example I split up my data set into
three shards so I'm pretending that
we're only storing one key value pair
per shard and in practice you'd have a
whole lot on each shard but in any case
you would have a disjoint set of them on
each but it would also be possible to
have a different design it would be
possible to have the data partitioned or
sharded but to have more than one
partition per node so for example we
could do this we could have something
like machine 1
machine-to-machine three
and then our clients over here
so now we have three machines like we
started with but the setup is a little
different right
we have replication so for example we
have two copies of key X two of Qi and
two of key Z on different machines so we
get fault tolerance that way
but we're also splitting up the requests
so let's say that Z is getting a lot of
requests so and then let's say Z is
getting a lot of requests and x and y
are getting a lot of requests maybe it
makes sense to have Z stored in a
different place than x and y so you can
split up the load of requests that have
to be served so this way as you can see
these replicas still have to be kept
consistent with each other perky right
so this replica has to be able to keep
consistent with this replicas X so there
has to be communication between these
replicas here and it has to keep
consistent with this replicas Y so there
has to be back and forth conversation
here and similarly here and in fact the
way that you might design it would be to
have each replica acting as a primary
for some part of the data set and acting
like a backup for another part of the
data set so let's say that this replica
m1 is the primary four key X so I'll put
a P there and then this one over here is
the backup for key X so requests for
this key would goat would go here and
then for y m1 would act as a backup but
this machine down here would act as the
primary and for z m2 would act as the
primary and this machine would act as
the back
so every machine is is playing the role
as a primary for some part of the data
set and as a backup for another part
this helps split up the workload right
so if the clients need X they talk to
this machine if they need Y they talk to
this machine and if they need Z they
talk to this machine but we still have
replication in the sense that the data
is stored on different independent
machines so this is kind of nice right I
managed to split up the request load
coming from the clients but also have
replication so each machine is storing
here 2/3 of the full data set right so
this also could help solve the problem
although not not necessarily in in in
the same way that we did before but it
could help solve the problem of not
being able to store that the full data
set on one machine so every machine has
2/3 of the full data set so this is
another this is this is also sharding so
charting is important uh gives you
better throughput because you can serve
different parts of your data set from
different machines at the same time and
it makes it possible to store a data set
that's too big for any one node now if
you're not using a strongly consistent
replication strategy like dynamo then
maybe you already were serving requests
from different machines at the same time
right so Dynamo does this but you
definitely still need partitioning or
you definitely still need sharding if
you want to serve these sorts of larger
than can fit on one node data sets so
real systems are typically going to do
both replication and partitioning so
putting this this picture back here
so we can kind of think of this data set
as being for these these replicas is
being split up two different ways so X
is being replicated across these
different groups of machines and then
each of these groups of machines
together stores all the data so the
choice of the partitioning strategy or
the choice of the sharding strategy is
mostly orthogonal to the choice of the
replication strategy so in our
discussion today we're going to mostly
ignore replication and we're just going
to focus on partitioning so in my
diagrams all mostly just draw the
partitions and you can assume that
they're replicated somehow so I'll be
focusing in on the partitions like how
the data is split up among nodes and you
can assume that there is some
replication of those but how they're
replicated is not going to be our
concern for the moment so let's let's
take away the replicas from this picture
and just focus on partitions
and clients may talk to multiple
different partitions it depends what
data they want okay so say we have this
large amount of data we want to
partition it how do we decide which data
to put on which nodes so let's continue
to imagine that the data is these key
value pairs simple data model so which
key value pairs go where what would be a
strategy that you might use
or let me let me phrase it this way what
goals are we trying to accomplish with
our partitioning strategy so so for sure
we want the data to be evenly
distributed good
not much use in doing partitioning if it
all ends up in one place right um we
want to do that so that we avoid
hotspots right but we yeah right great
point we also want it to be easy for the
client to find we want it to be fast and
easy
so these goals kind of feel like they're
in tension with one another right like
if we if we put all the data on one node
then it's really really easy for the
client to figure out where to find it
right they know it's all there but on
the other hand that that kind of blows
apart our goal of trying to evenly
distribute the data so we want we want
to evenly distribute the data but we
also want it to be easy for the client
to find the data um let me throw out
another possibility if we just randomly
assigned a key value pairs to nodes then
that would probably do a pretty good job
of spreading out the data but it would
also make it very hard for the client to
find the data that they wanted so
neither of those are great ideas so we
could sort of make a little table here
of the options so if this is goal one
this is goal two so if we choose
randomly distributing the data then
it'll end up being evenly distributed
more or less but it definitely won't be
easy for the client to find what they
want and if we don't partition at all
let me put it all on one node then sure
it'll be easy for the client to find but
it won't be evenly distributed at all so
those are both bad ideas um so what else
are what else can we do
you
so a good suggestion was made actually a
little while ago in chat um that had to
do with with hashing the keys so before
I talk about that just as a straw man
let's let's think about another
possibility we can say every partition
will will store a particular range of
the keys so this is called partitioning
by key range so for instance if my keys
are some sort of alphabetical strings um
then I could say that m1 is responsible
for a through H and M 2 is responsible
for AI through R and M 3 is responsible
for s through Z so maybe we have like B
equals 3 here and I'm trying to remember
the alphabet P equals 5 here and y
equals 4 here something like that okay
so this seems to work partitioning by
key range and some systems do something
like this but what's the downside of
doing it this way
right what if this is how you set things
up and then the right start coming in
and they're all like Oh less equals ten
and z equals five x equals nine so you'd
end up with this uneven distribution of
data because your keys were not
uniformly distributed across the space
of letters so now your data is unevenly
distributed across the server's so key
partitioning by key range probably is
not a good way to go unless you had some
way of knowing in advance that your
requests were going to be adding a
uniform distribution of keys or or
requesting a uniform distribution of
keys but there's hope right we can solve
this problem really really easily what
is a way to take data that's not
uniformly distributed and make it
uniformly distributed
hashing right a hash function so a good
hash function will take our possibly
wildly uneven distribution of keys and
will distribute them evenly across its
output space um so let's take md5 for
instance so md5 is a function from from
its input space to its output space its
input space is going to be the keys in
this case so and its output space is
going to be numbers from zero to so md5
returns a 128-bit hash right so this is
going to be 2 to the 128th minus 1 so
strings are keys probably with some
fixed length limit we hashed them with
them md5 we get outputs in this range
and they'll be more or less evenly
spaced over that range so if our input
strings are like no maybe that'll get
hash to hear aardvark
it'll get hash to hear Platypus good
hash to hear maybe
zzzzz you know get hash to hear
hmm what's an animal that so the hope is
that even if your keys aren't evenly
distributed across the input space the
output of the hash function will be so
okay then we have a way to distribute
the keys evenly across the nodes we just
give every node an evenly sized piece of
the output space right so we might say
okay machine one gets this piece of the
output space and machine two gets this
piece of the output space and machine
three gets this piece so one way to do
or so that's the way that I've drawn it
here but actually the way that you might
more likely do this is say just take the
output space of the hash function and if
you want to split over say three nodes
do mod three of the hashed value so if I
want to know where to put the key value
pair whose key is aardvark then first I
hash it to get this 128 bit hash value
and then I do mod 3 of that the output
of mod 3 is gonna be 0 1 or 2 and then
that's going to tell me which of my
three nodes to put the key value pair on
so so this is actually the wrong picture
to split it up this way it would
actually be more like individual stripes
where like like zero here hashes to em 1
and 1 hashes to em 2 and 3 hashes to em
three or two hashes to M 3 and so on
so this is a good approach because if I
want to look up a key and I need to know
where to find it I just do the same
thing I calculate its hash and then do
mod 3 or mod n for whatever number of
nodes that I that I have and this could
be done either on the client side or on
the datastore side so so a better
approach than simply splitting by key
range is this
hash of key mod n approach where n is
the number of shards that you have so
this is good but what's the catch of
doing it this way can anybody think of
any problems with using this approach
yeah okay hash collisions but I mean
we're not going to worry too much about
that right we're going to assume that we
have a reasonably good hash function so
okay it might not be perfect but but but
but collisions aren't our primary
concern with doing it this way so a
great point was just raised in chat
which was that this is not necessarily
resilient to replica failure okay so so
what could be the problem well what if
the number of nodes changes right so in
general in distributed systems we want
to be able to address the problem of
things changing over time right maybe
we're getting more queries right so we
want to be able to add a machine to let
us handle all those queries or our
dataset grows right and we want to add a
machine to help store our the all the
data or a machine fails and we want to
be able to keep on accepting rights to
data that happened to be in a shard on
that failed machine so the trouble with
doing this this hash of key mod n thing
is that if n changes most of the data
gets moved around so let's say n changes
from 3 to 4 let's say that we added
another machine here so we had 3
machines now we have 4 before we did md5
of aardvark and we got M be md5 of
aardvark mod 3 right and we got let's
say zero I don't actually know what the
md5 of aardvark is you can try it
yourself if you want but let's say that
we did md5 of aardvark mod 3 and got 0
now we do md5 of aardvark mod 4 and we
get something else say we get 2 so now
that key needs to move from machine 0 to
machine 2 or machine 1 to M 1 to M 3
because our indexing here was from 1 so
that seems kind of messed up
right if we added a new machine
it's understandable that we're gonna
need to move some data around because
when we add a new machine we have to
move some data to the new machine but
instead of moving data to the new
machine like let's say so so in this
case we added m4 right so it would make
sense that some data has to get moved
over to this this this new machine m4
but as a result of using this hash of
key mod end strategy we moved aardvark
from one old machine to another old
machine so that's that that seems
unnecessary right when we add a new
machine
we shouldn't have to move data from an
old machine to a different old machine
just to accommodate the the existence of
this new machine so in an ideal world we
would do the minimum amount of data
movement necessary so the trouble with
this hash of key mod n thing is that if
the number of nodes changes then we end
up having to do unnecessary data
movement I'll write that down
okay so that that raises the question
what is the minimum amount of data
movement necessary if we want the data
to be evenly split between notes so
let's say that we have six keys on three
notes so about two per node right they
might not be exactly evenly split but
let's suppose that they are so let's
let's put some keys here
okay so those are our three nodes now
let's say that we add one note so there
are now six keys and four notes here's
our shiny new node because we have six
keys and four nodes how many keys should
we have per node on average yeah one and
a half six divided by four or one and a
half well we can't really move one and a
half nodes or we can't move one and a
half keys so we have to move either one
or to say it's one okay so say this key
moves to the new node so that's the
minimum movement possible to achieve an
even split so in general if you have
some number of keys K here we had six
but in general if you have K and you
have n nodes then how many keys do you
have to move in general its K divided by
n so
that's the number of keys that have to
be moved to ensure an even split or a
split as even as possible I should say
the number of keys that have to be moved
to ensure an even split
when end changes so we would like to
come up with a with a partitioning
strategy that only moves K over N nodes
and we accomplish this using something
called consistent hashing which you
might remember from the Dynamo paper
consistent hashing this is another one
of those unfortunate distributed systems
terminology collisions so here we're
using the word consistent in a totally
different way from where we meant it
before when we were talking about
consistency models unfortunate collision
this is just what it's called
this idea emerged more from the
networking community so maybe that's why
there's this the this naming collision
so the idea is that we arrange our nodes
in a ring
so here's m1 here's M - here's m3 B
here's m4 and the points around this
ring correspond to the output space of
our hash function so we were using md5
right which we said had this huge output
space ranging from 0 to 2 to the 128th
minus 1 um let's look that's too big of
a number to think about so let's pick
something manageable so let's just say
that this the the points around this
rang correspond to 0 to 2 63 so here's 0
here's 1 and this goes around like this
and then here's 63 so in practice this
would be a much bigger number but we'll
pick a simpler number just for the sake
of example and then we can mark some
other points around here so like that
maybe this would be 16
[Music]
maybe I'm 1 is it 8 maybe I'm - is it 20
M 3 is at 32 maybe M 4 is at 47 so each
of our nodes is going to belong to a
particular point on the ring we don't
really care what point but we calculate
this somehow maybe we maybe we hash the
IP address of the node using our hash
function or something like that and then
the nodes will be more or less evenly
spaced around the ring maybe not
perfectly spaced but more or less evenly
spaced if our if our hash function has
good behavior now let's say somebody
wants to add a key value pair let's say
the key is Apple so we hash the key just
like before we hash the key of Apple and
and let's say the hash functions output
is 14
so we go to pour point 14 on the ring
there's probably not a node there so
what we do is we walk around the ring
clockwise until we hit the first node in
this case it's m2 so the key Apple gets
stored there so a key belongs on the
server that it's it's that is its
successor on the ring
so if somebody wants to look up a key
same deal if you want to look up Apple
you hash the the value of the key Apple
you hash the key you get 14 you walk
around the circle until you hit a node
and that's the place where you're going
to find the key that you wanted and the
circle wraps around so let's say that
let's say that I'm trying to look up the
key aardvark and let's say that aardvark
hashes to 62
so on what machine will that key be
stored
right it'll be on m1 so in dynamo they
also use this ring to decide where to
replicate things um so let's say that
the replication factor is three that
means that everything has to be
replicated three times the way that they
do it is for any key it has a home node
which is the node that it hashes to
using this approach that I just sketched
out here and then you store it there so
Apple gets stored here but it also gets
stored at the node after that and the
node after that until you have it stored
in three places so you could choose
different different replication factors
if you chose a replication factor of two
then it might just be stored here in
here so um so that's how they that's how
they choose where to replicate keys so
in dynamo every node has what the paper
calls a preference list meaning the
places where that nodes data will be
replicated to and the preference list
will actually be longer than three I say
if three were the replication factor the
preference list would actually be longer
than that does anybody remember why the
preference list is actually longer
it's cuz notes could be down right or
unavailable for whatever reason so they
still try to replicate in however many
many places if the replication factor is
three then they'll try to replicate in
three places even if one of the nodes
where they're supposed to be replicating
is down they just keep going down the
preference list until they find three
nodes that are actually up and then
later if those nodes come back up they
might try to replicate to them okay so
we started talking about this whole
consistent hashing strategy because we
wanted to solve this issue of too much
data getting moved around when we added
or remove nodes and we wanted to make
sure that we moved as little data as
necessary so how does consistent hashing
solve that well let's add a new node to
the Ring call it m5 okay so I've added a
new node here let's say it's at 60 so
now that I've added this new node which
keys do I have to move so what are the
ranges that Keys store well we said that
keys belong on the node that there's
that is their successor on the ring
right so the keys that come from let's
see 9 to 20 are going to go onto m2
and three is going to get the ones from
21 to 30 to m4 well what a time for have
previously it got yeah m4 yeah m4 got
everything from 33 to 47 and what did m1
have previously well before this m5 got
added and one was responsible for this
whole space right they were responsible
from it for everything from 48 up to
eight but then we just put in m5 here so
which part of m1 s key space does m5 now
take over
that's right yeah so m5 is now
responsible for this chunk of keys right
here so now I'm one is only responsible
for I guess 61 through eight so now that
we've added this new note of m5 which
keys do we have to move the only ones
that we have to move are the ones that
are in this range from 48 to 60 and
where were those stored before they were
stored on m1 so m1 is going to have to
take this whole range here was what m1
was responsible for before m1 is going
to have to take a chunk of its data and
hand it over to m5 but on average it
will only have to move that K over n
number of keys where K is the total keys
that are stored and n is the number of
nodes and these other replicas over or
these other sorry not replicas these
other nodes over here m2 m3 m4
they aren't affected at all they can be
totally oblivious to the fact that all
this was going on so they don't even
have to care that a new node entered the
system so that's great
it's great when you don't have to care
what's going on in another part of the
system and distributed systems okay so
that's what we do when a note is added
it takes over part of the key range from
its neighbor all right what about when a
node crashes suppose m2 goes away who is
affected by that
so which note is gonna have to take over
right so m2 was responsible for these
keys right it was responsible for the
keys from 9 to 20 so now somebody has to
take over it's in particular its
neighbour m3 has to take over for those
keys so m3 has to take those keys on now
m3 is going to get this whole range but
these other nodes m4 m5 and m1 are
unaffected it's business as usual for
them this actually works really nicely
in dynamo because whatever keys are
being stored on a node as the home node
for those keys
they're also being replicated onto its
successors so if a node crashes and its
successor node has to take over it's
part of the of the key space then
hopefully it has the backup already so
it can just say ok those keys that I was
serving as a backup for now they live
here I'm their home now and of course at
this point
whoever's operating this system will
probably want to bring another node up
but until they do the neighbor node will
pick up the slack for them and that's
consistent hashing alright we have four
minutes left and I haven't done the quiz
yet so let me put up the quiz and I'm
actually going to leave it up longer
than the end of class just so that
everybody has time to do it
okay so I'll leave this open longer than
the end of class but we have about two
minutes left tonight and I want to talk
about really briefly a couple of ways
that consistent hashing might go wrong
so can you think of any ways that this
consistent hashing strategy might go
wrong don't worry about doing the quiz
immediately because I'll leave it up for
a while
yeah so if somebody's suggestion is a
node could take on a range that's too
large for it to handle yeah so that
could happen if the nodes are not evenly
spread around the ring so that that
could happen right um we know that a
good hash function is going to map its
inputs over its output range as evenly
as possible but if you have not very
many inputs then you can't necessarily
expect the output space to be evenly
covered the more inputs there are the
more likely it is that you'll get this
even distribution so actually a trick
that you can play is actually have each
node be hashed to several points in the
ring so a node instead of just being
hashed to one point of the ring that
node might pretend to be thirty nodes or
eighty nodes and each one is going to
have its own identifier which gets
hashed to a position on the ring and
this makes an even distribution more
likely just statistically speaking
so those eighty or however many nodes
they are are called virtual nodes so
virtual node is a virtual nodes are when
a node a fit a particular physical node
is hashed to many points on the ring
the other thing about virtual nodes in
addition to improving the distribution
of nodes on the ring and this is an
advantage that they actually bring up in
the dynamo paper the other nice thing
about virtual nodes is that you could
have a different number of virtual nodes
per physical node to account for
differences in storage capacity on the
physical nodes so let's say you have a
machine and it has like a 1 terabyte
hard drive maybe you give it a certain
number of virtual nodes maybe you give
it like 20 virtual nodes another machine
has a 2 terabyte drive so you can give
it 40 virtual nodes so the machines that
have more capacity can then be
responsible for bigger slices of the
space of keys yeah there's the dot cam
again sorry so so virtual nodes are when
a physical node is hashed to many points
on the ring so that's that's what
virtual nodes do for you
they both allow the the nodes to be more
evenly distributed around the ring and
they also have this nice side benefit
where you could have a different number
of virtual nodes per physical node
depending on the storage capacity of
those physical nodes um we're almost out
of time but just really briefly I want
to mention a downside of using virtual
nodes so one is that when if a node
that's represented by many virtual nodes
goes down then lots of separate areas on
the ring are affected right and lots of
nodes would have to step up to be
responsible for those parts of the ring
but in the Dynamo paper they actually
advertise that as a feature they say
that if a node dies it's good to have
its load spread out right rather than
just have its immediate neighbor take it
on so I can see why that would make
sense but but it's maybe a little bit
harder for us to reason about so a nice
thing about not using virtual nodes is
that it's nice and obvious what happens
if the node dies right its neighbor
takes on its its keys and the other
downside of virtual nodes
that replication gets more complicated
because you want to make sure you don't
want to replicate to virtual nodes that
are actually the same physical machine
or rather you sorry you don't you you
want to make sure not to replicate to
two different virtual nodes if those
virtual nodes are actually the same
physical machine because then you you're
replicating but you're not actually
getting the fault tolerance that comes
from having them stored on independent
machines because that wouldn't provide
fault tolerance so you have to be more
careful in how you do replication but
virtual nodes like despite these
downsides which are which are primarily
engineering issues virtual nodes this
this way of that this this technique of
hashing a particular physical nodes to
many points in the ring this is how it
tends to be done in practice we're way
over time already sorry about the late
start and the technical difficulties
today so I'm going to wrap up but let me
know if you have questions on Friday
we're going to have a an exciting class
because we're going to have some some
recent grads who are going to come in
and do a Q&A session and talk to you
about their experience working with
distributed systems since graduation and
hopefully they'll also talk about job
searching in the age of Kovan 19 and
other tough topics like that so I will
see you on Friday
take care